alright so in the world of chainsaw man
the angel devil is easily one of the
best characters and despite having the
appearance of a 12 year old child he's
also one of the strongest today we're
going to be breaking down exactly what
makes him so interesting and by the end
you'll understand his full backstory the
nature of his abilities and the sad
reason why makama ruined his life before
we get into it though don't forget to
sub to the channel for more chainsaw man
videos like this especially if you're
interested in seeing episode breakdowns
for the anime when it comes out
okay so for anyone watching who might
not know how devils are created in this
series i'm going to do a brief
explanation just that the rest of the
video makes sense to start things off
there are two locations we need to be
aware of the first being hell which is
the dimension where all devils are first
born and the second location being earth
the way things work is that if enough
people on earth fear something then
eventually a devil representing that
fear will manifest in hell an easy
example is how humans fear of darkness
led to the creation of the darkness
devil the angel devil is the same in
that he was born out of humanity's fear
of angels and if we consider for a
second just how terrifying biblically
accurate angels are then yeah it makes
sense why a lot of people would be
afraid anyway while it's true that the
underworld is a completely separate
dimension there are still ways for
devils to escape with the most common
method being reincarnation what this
means is that if the devil is killed in
hell then following its death it gets
reincarnated somewhere on the planet
where it now has the chance to eat as
many people as it wants to as a result
most countries employ devil hunters to
help protect their population and this
is what brings us to angel's tragic
backstory originally when the angel
devil first reincarnated on earth he was
born in a tropical island with no memory
of his past life and it didn't take long
for him to blend in with the local
village unlike most devils he never had
the urge to kill anyone since it was
confirmed in chapter 34 that devils who
look human tend to be more friendly
towards people that's why in this
tropical paradise he was able to make
friends with the villagers who taught
him how to speak their language and
built him his own house eventually he
also got into a relationship with one of
the local women and it seemed like he
had a peaceful existence where most of
his days were spent either swimming or
relaxing on the beach however this all
began to change when makima arrived and
for those who don't know makima is a
high-ranking devil hunter that works for
the japanese government her motivation
for attracting him to this remote
village is revealed later in the series
where it's explained that during his
previous life in hell angel was a loyal
disciple of the chainsaw devil for
making his own reason she'd been
searching for the chainsaw devil for a
long time and along the way she hunted
down seven of his disciples with angel
now being the eighth following a brief
introduction she uses her abilities to
force him to demonstrate his power and
while under her control the angel devil
massacres the entire village including
his girlfriend impressed by his raw
talent machima then erases his memory
and brings him to tokyo where he's made
to work as a devil hunter alongside
other former disciples of chainsaw man
before we go any further though it's
probably best that we explain what his
amazing power is since makame even said
that his potential makes him the
strongest agent they have to put it
simply the angel devil has three unique
abilities the first of which is that he
drains the life force of any human he
touches by making even the smallest
contact with someone he instantly
decreases their lifespan and if that
contact is maintained for too long the
person he's touching will eventually die
this is the method that was used to wipe
out his home village when makima was
controlling him and on a separate
occasion aki's lifespan was reduced by
two months after the two of them briefly
touched hands a quirk like this makes
angel one of the most dangerous
characters to be around but in a similar
way to rogue from the x-men movies he
hates his own powers and usually avoids
touching people unless he has to now
moving on to his second ability the
angel devil can create supernatural
weapons that are made from the life
force of his victims as an example when
he drained his girlfriend he likely
stole at least 40 to 50 years from her
lifespan and then later on when he was
ready he used 10 of those years to
produce this magical sword here we can
see that a halo is used to generate
these new weapons and their supernatural
power varies depending on how many years
were needed to manifest it in chapter 35
a katana that angel made was used to
kill a devil that should have been
impossible to cut through and in chapter
60 he used five years of life to create
a sword that slices people without
leaving a scratch these are both clear
demonstrations of his insane potential
but there's a good reason why he
generally doesn't like producing these
weapons when angel was first introduced
he had at least 1 120 years worth of
life that he'd absorbed from other
people and he later confessed how these
victims would sometimes haunt him in his
nightmares because of this he often
hesitates to use their life force to
create these weapons and on one occasion
he even apologized for using their
lifespans in this way
finally angel's last unique power is
that he has bulletproof wings that can
block gunfire from close range but as of
making this video there hasn't been any
confirmation that the wings also allow
him to fly
anyhow with that said it's time to
explore the remaining personality traits
that make him such an intriguing
character and to do this we need to
flash back to the first few volumes of
the manga in those early volumes it was
plain to see that to be a devil hunter
you need to have a specific reason for
taking the job whether that reason be
revenge family commitments or something
more ridiculous
even devils like power had a goal that
they wanted to accomplish but when it
came to angel he genuinely had no
purpose from his perspective nothing
about being a devil hunter made life
worth living and this lack of motivation
led to him constantly slacking around
and at one point admitting that he'd
rather die to continue working his
outspoken nature and sluggish demeanor
made for a pretty entertaining combo but
as an audience we sympathize with angel
because not only was he the unhappiest
devil but he's also the most human
despite the fact that he's supposed to
be a bloodthirsty creature angel
demonstrates human emotions like empathy
when he tells a dying woman she's going
to heaven he demonstrates regret
regarding the lies he's had to take and
of course he demonstrated love and when
you combine all of those things together
you get a unique devil who's closer to
being human than certain human
characters in the series
now before we end the video i'm gonna do
some quick fire trivia but fair warning
there will be spoilers from this point
forward
okay so point number one is that the
angel devil likely had a completely
different appearance during his first
life as it's been proven that devils
take on a new form when they get
reincarnated this opens up the
possibility that in hell angel did
actually look like a biblically accurate
angel but it's also possible that he
still look like a human with alternate
features
point number two is that in the latest
popularity poll japanese readers ranked
angel as the seventh most popular
character with his devil hunting partner
aki being ranked in first place point
number three is that the first time
makame puts him under her control she
comes out of nowhere and approaches him
on the beach but the second time he goes
under her control the reverse happens
with him being the one to approach her
on the beach point number four is that
for some unusual reason angel's arms
didn't regenerate after being cut up by
the darkness devil but in chapter 89 we
see that both of his arms have now
returned likely thanks to makima's
influence point number five is that most
of the former disciples of chainsaw man
remembered one thing from their time in
hell which is the sound of his chainsaw
engine before they died the only
exception to this is the shark fiend who
seems to have a clear memory of what the
chainsaw devil was like and he even
explains to denji how exactly chainsaw
used to use his powers this implies that
the shark devil might not have actually
died and been reincarnated like everyone
else but instead maybe he was captured
in hell and then somehow brought to
earth by makima
lastly the final bit of trivia is about
the town mouse and the country mouse
this tale is one of esol's famous short
stories anthony chainsaw man several
characters gave their perspective on
which mouse they'd rather be the way the
story goes is that the town mouse gets
to live in a big house in the city and
eat all the best food but has a high
risk of being killed by either cats or
humans by contrast the country mask gets
to live in relative safety in the
countryside but doesn't get to have the
luxuries that come with being a town
mouse in chainsaw man characters like
denji preferred being the town mouse
because he values having fun more than a
life of peace but in angel's case we
know that he belongs in the country and
the fact that makima brought into the
city is exactly why he's so depressed on
a personal level i lean more towards
being a country mouse as well however
let me know down below in the comments
which mask you'd rather be also don't
forget to subscribe if you enjoyed the
video and leave a like if you want to
see more chainsaw man content like this
thanks for watching as always and until
the next one peace out